Ben you're conservative Destiny you're a
liberal can you each describe what key
values underpin your philosophy on
politics and maybe life in the context
of this left right political Spectrum
you want to go first yeah so I think
that we have a huge country full of a
lot of people a lot of individual
talents
capabilities um and I think that the
goal of government broadly speaking
should be to try to ensure that
everybody is able to achieve as much as
possible so on a liberal level that
usually means some people might need a
little bit of a boost when it comes to
things like education um they might need
a little bit of a boost when it comes to
providing certain Necessities like
housing or food or clothing but broadly
speaking I mean I'm still a liberal not
a communist or a socialist I don't
believe in the you know total command
economy total communist takeover of all
of the uh you know economy but I think
that broadly speaking the government
should kind of like kick in and help
people when they need it and that
government can and should be big not
necessarily I notic that when liberals
talk about government or especially
taxes it seems like they talk about it
for taxes sake or big bigness sake so
people talk about taxes sometimes as
like a like a punishment like tax the
rich uh I think taxing the rich is fine
in so far as it funds the programs that
we want to fund but Democrats have a
really big problem demonizing success or
wealth and I don't think that's a bad
thing uh I I don't think it's a bad
thing to be wealthy to be a billionaire
or whatever as long as we're funding
what we need to fund and what do you
think it means to be a conservative
what's what's the philosophy that
underlies your political view so first
of all I'm glad that Destiny you're
already coming out as a republican
that's exciting um I mean I I we hold a
lot in common in terms of uh you know
the the basic idea
that people ought to have as much
opportunity as possible and also in so
far as the government should do the
minimum amount necessary to interfere in
people's lives in order to pursue
certain functions particularly at the
local level so a lot of governmental
discussions on a pragmatic level end up
being discussions about where government
ought to be involved but also at what
level government ought to be involved
and I have an incredibly subsidiary view
of government I I think that you know
local governments because you have
higher levels of homogenity and and
consent uh are capable of doing more
things and as you abstract up the chain
it becomes more and more impractical and
more more divisive to to do more things
in in my view government is basically
there to preserve certain key Liberties
uh the those key Liberties pre-exist the
government uh in in so far as they are
more important than what priorities the
government has the the job of government
is to maintain for example National
Defense protection of property rights
protection of religious freedom the
these are these are the key focuses of
government as generally expressed in the
Bill of Rights in the Constitution and I
agree with the general philosophy of the
Bill of Rights and the Constitution now
that doesn't mean by the way that you
can't do more on a governmental level
again as you get closer to the ground
which by the way is also embedded in the
Constitution people forget the
Constitution was originally applied to
the federal government not to local and
state government um but you know if I
going to Define conservatism it would
actually be a little broader than that
because I think to understand how people
interact with government you have to go
to kind of core values and so for me
there there are a couple of premises one
human beings have a nature that nature
is neither good nor bad we have aspects
of goodness and we have aspects of
Badness human beings are sinful we have
temptations and what that means is that
we have to be careful not to incentivize
the bad and that we should incentivize
the good human beings do have agency and
are capable of making decisions in the
vast majority of circumstances um and it
is better for a society if we act as
though they do uh second the basic idea
of human nature there is an idea in my
view that all human beings have equal
value before the law I'm I'm a religious
person so I'd say equal value before God
but I think that's also sort of a key
tant of Western Civilization being
non-religious or religious that every
individual has equivalent value in sort
of cosmic terms um but that does not
necessarily mean that every person is
equally equipped to do everything
equally well and so it is not the job of
government to rectify every imbalance of
Life The Quest for Cosmic justice as
Thomas Soul suggests is something that
government is generally incapable of
doing and more often than not botches
and makes things worse so those are a
few key tenants and that that tends to
materialize in in a variety of ways the
the the easiest way to sum that up would
the traditional kind of three legs of
the the conservative stool although now
obviously there's a very fragmented
conservative movement in the United
States would be a a socially
conservative view in which family is the
chief institution of society like the
little platoon of society as Edmund
Burke suggested uh in which free free
markets and property rights are
extraordinarily valuable and necessary
uh because every individual has the
ability to be creative with their
property and to freely alienate that
property uh and uh and finally I tend
toward a hawkish foreign policy that
suggests that the world is not filled
with wonderful people who all agree with
us and think like us and those people
will pursue adversarial interests if we
if we do not protect our own interests
can I ask a question on that I'm so okay
so okay um I'm excited for this
conversation because I consider you to
be really intelligent um but I feel like
sometimes there are ways that
conservatives talk about certain issues
that seem to defy logic and reason I
guess so here and I'm sure you feel the
same way about prog I feel the same way
progressives um but even some uh
liberals for sure uh before I ask this
question it's going to relate to
education we can agree broadly speaking
that statistics are real and that not
everybody could do everything so for a
grounded example uh my life was pretty
bad I got into streaming and I turned my
life around and that was really cool but
I can't expect everybody to do what I
did right like everybody being able to
join the NBA or to be like a streamer of
course everybody has different qualities
sure okay so I used to be a lot more
libertarian um when I was 2021 and one
of the things that dramatically changed
kind of my view on government uh
manipulation of things in the I guess in
society came uh when it came time to
deal with my son and the school that he
went to and one of the things that I
noticed was when it came time to send my
son to school I could to do private
education or I could do public uh
personally I did 12 Years of Catholic
private education um however the public
schools in Nebraska depending on what
you lived were very very very good and I
opted for a certain District I bought a
house there I moved there and my son was
able to go to those schools um and he's
been going through those schools and the
difference of availability of like
technology like these kids are taking
home iPads and like first grade uh
they've got like huge computer labs and
everything do you think that there is
some type of I don't want to say
Injustice or unfairness because I'm not
even looking at it that way just
pragmatically that there might be
children that are in certain schools
that if they just had better funding or
more uh access to Technologies or things
available to them that those kids would
become more productive members of
society that with like a little bit of a
help they they could actually achieve
more and do better for all of society so
I think that on the list of priorities
when it comes to education the
availability of technology is actually
fairly low on the list of priorities
sure the two things I've heard are food
availability and I think air
conditioning I think are the two biggest
ones that I hear but sure well I mean
the the biggest thing in terms of
Education itself not just the physical
facilities that we're talking about
would actually be two parent family
households sure communities that that
have fathers in them is actually number
one decid start according to Roland
frier and many studies done on this
particular topic and the idea that that
money alone that investment of resources
is the top priority in schooling is
boted by the fact that LAUSD which is
where I went to school when I was
younger they pour an enormous amount of
money into LAUSD we're talking about
tens of thousands of dollars very often
per student and it does not result in
better schooling outcomes and so when
you say if we could give every kid an
iPad would you give every kid an iPad
the question is not if I had a rep
replicator machine from Star Trek would
I give everybody an enormous amount of
stuff sure I I would every every
resource is finite every resource is
limited and you have to prioritize what
are the what are the outcomes that you
seek in terms of the means with which
you are seeking them and so again I
think that the question is is I I
quibble with the with the premise of the
question which is that again the the
chief Injustice when it comes to
education on the list of of injustices
is lack of availability to technology or
that it's a funding problem I I just
don't think that's the case sure and I
can half agree with you there but I
don't think any amount of changes in the
schools will create two parent
households right we can't bring a I
totally agree with you that's why I
think that the the fundamental
educational problem is not in fact a
schooling problem I think that it
pre-exists that sure but then I feel
like we're now I feel like this is kind
of the conservative marry go around
where it's like what can we do to help
with schools so two of the things that
I've seen I think that are usually
brought up in research is one is air
conditioning that children in hotter
environments just don't learn as well um
and then the second second one is access
to food so like kids that are given like
a breakfast or a lunch that's provided
at school like increases educational
outcomes now I agree that neither of
these things might be determinative in
like well 20% of kids were graduating
and now 80% of kids are graduating or
these kids are all going you know from
with their geds into the workforce and
now these kids are all suddenly becoming
Engineers but in terms of where we can
help do you think there should be like
some minimum threshold or minimum
Baseline of like at the very least every
school should have a non-leaky gym or
every school should have uh if children
can't afford lunch or breakfast like
some sort of food provided or every
school should have these like Baseline
things so again I'm going to quibble
with the premise of the question because
I think when it comes to for example
food
insecurity School food programs again
you can always pour money into any
program and at the margins create change
I mean there's no doubt that pouring
money onto anything will create change
in a Marginal Way the question is how
large is the margin and how big is the
movement right so the Delta is what I'm
looking at and so I I think that the
you're you're starting at a second order
question which is what if we ignore what
I would think are the big primary
questions of Education namely family
structure value of education at home how
much you have parents who are capable or
willing to help with homework what are
the incentive structures we can set up
for a society that actually facilitate
that how local communities take
ownership of their schools is a big one
right all all of these issues we're
ignoring in favor of say air
conditioning or lunch programs and so in
a vacuum if you say air conditioning and
lunch programs sounds great in a vacuum
in in terms of prioritization of values
and cost structure are those the things
that I think are going to move the in a
major way in terms of public
policy I I I do not and in fact I think
that many of them end up being
disproportionate wastes of money I mean
I've talked before pretty
controversially about the fact that an
enormous amount of school lunch programs
are thrown out like an enormous amount
of that food ends up in the garbage can
is there a better way to do that if
there is a better way to do it then I'm
perfectly willing to hear about that
better way to do it but it seems to me
that one of the big flaws in the way
that many people of the left approach
government is what if we hit every knet
with a hammer and my question is what if
the Gat isn't even the problem what if
there's a much bigger substructure
problem that needs to be solved in order
to if you're shifting deck chairs on the
Titanic sure you can make the Titanic
slightly more balanced because the deck
chairs are slightly better oriented but
the real question is the the water
that's gaping into the Titanic right
yeah and I agree with you 100% but again
that I feel like we're on the
conservative Mar then of never wanting
to address as conservative merry round I
can I can give you 10 ways well sure but
so like here would be the merry round I
would say that like there's a minimum
funding for schools that I think would
help children and then we go well the
thing that would help them the most is
two parent households and I go okay well
two parent households actually aren't
the problem um the issue is access to
things like birth controls that people
don't have children early on and it's
like but the issue isn't actually birth
control the issue is actually you need a
certain amount of money to move out
early and to get married and then to
have a two parent household so it's
actually like Economic Opportunity well
it's no just two parent households yeah
but like what is the what are the pre
people before you're married and
have babies sure done that's great we
can say that and try to fight against
you know however many hundreds of
thousands of years of human evolution
but people will have sex and people will
make babies and then they used to get
married the vast majority of people in
this country with kids used to be
married the vast majority of people with
kids in this country now are not married
increasingly that obviously a societal
change something changed it wasn't human
evolution but a lot of those things in
terms of resting on whether or not
people get married have to do with
financial decisions do you have the
money people are worse off now than they
were 50 60 years ago when the marriage
rates were higher people are delaying
the start of their careers because
education's going increasingly important
so in in other words people are richer
now and they have more education now and
yet they're having babies out of wedlock
now because they're richer and have more
education I'm saying that the one of the
biggest indicators for whether or not
somebody's willing to get married is how
much money both people are making if
they can move out of their household
people don't tend to want to get married
at 22 when they've just finished College
when they don't have the money to move
out and they can't afford a house
because we have changed the moral status
of marriage in the culture meaning that
everyone poor Rich and in between used
to get married that is by the way a huge
percentage of marriages in the United
States used to be what they would call
shotgun marriages meaning that somebody
knocked somebody up and because they did
not want the baby to be born outside of
a two- parent household they would then
get married do we think that shotgun
marriages though are a way to bring back
equilibrium to education that if we yes
absolutely yes 100% child deserves a
mother and a father because that is the
basis for all of this including
education do we think that shotgun
marriages are well let's say this do we
think that that's a reasonable direction
that society would ever take or is this
like yes it was the reasonable direction
for nearly all of modern history was but
history Moves In One Direction right why
because of time mean people people don't
think that in in what in what way is is
and I don't think we've ever like
regressed social standards back to like
oh well let's go 100 years back and do
things that you know used to exist
before I where the entire left right now
is arguing that we regress social
standards by rejecting Ro versus Wade so
that's obviously not true the Rover Wade
is not a social standard it's a Supreme
Court ruling number one number two what
if you read the actual majority of
opinion on roie Wade we can see that
socially we have actually never made
huge progress on how Society viewed
abortion this has always been an
incredibly divisive thing right even
that was I think part of alito's uh
writing on it was that things like gay
marriage for instance we've kind of
moved past and it's not really as
debated anymore but abortion was never a
SLE
topic The Arc of History constantly
Moves In One Direction is Bei by nearly
all of the 20th century what do we mean
by that I mean I mean the first halfth
Cur barbarism communism Nazism all of
that was a regression from what was
happening at for example the beginning
of the 19th century in the 20th century
what in what way Nazism and communism
Wen a regression from what was going on
in 1905 these are well in terms of like
communism being a regression for
instance I'm not a communist but like
the industrialization of the Soviet
Union happened under a communist Society
the
murder of T of millions of people that a
regression moral regression which is
what we are talking about now moral
regression and you're you're suggesting
that moral regression I wouldn't term a
return to Traditional Values a moral
regression you would but your suggestion
is that history only Moves In One
Direction and I'm suggesting that
history does not only move in in One
Direction it tends to move actually back
and forth sure I don't think that all of
history moves in one uh One Direction
there are going to be Wars there are
going to be times of peace I think in
general we're more peaceful now than we
have been in the past but I think when
we look at the way that people live
their lives I think that we tend to move
in a certain direction socially so when
it comes to things like racism or when
it comes to things like slavery or
women's rights I think that there are
two huge things that probably aren't
changing in the US and one is access to
contraception and one is women working
jobs I think that these two things are
probably huge things that are moving us
off of shotgun marriages or getting
married very early on and I don't see
though do you think that those two
things are going to change fundamentally
first of all what the data tend to show
is that actually more Highly Educated
people as you were saying tend to get
married more so the idea is that women
getting an education somehow throws them
off marriage it's the opposite
usually those women AR getting shotgun
marriages those women aren't having
children now you're Shing the topic my
my topic was how to get more people
married and what I'm s and and then you
suggested that higher levels of
Education are delaying marriage and
making it less probable and what I'm
telling you because this is what the
data suggests is that actually as you
raise up the the educational ladder
people tend to be married more than they
are lower down on the educational ladder
if you're a high school graduate you're
less likely to be married than than if
you're a postdoc I agree with you but
that's because one of the biggest
precursors to getting married is having
like a level of economic stability so as
people get more educated they obtain
this economic stability and then they're
in a more comfortable position to
explore more serious relation there's
another confound there I mean the
confound is that people in stable
marriages tend to be the children of
stable marriages and there's only one
way to break that cycle which is to
create a stable marriage and that is
something that is in everyone's hands
again this notion that it is somehow an
unbreakable unshadow barrier to get
married and have kids I don't understand
where this is coming from why is that
such a why is that such a challenge
think it's unbreakable or unshatter I
was just the initial point was for
school if we can provide a minimum level
of educational stuff for children that'
probably be good but when we Retreat
back to well it has to be the families
that are fixed first fixing families is
a multivariant problem I am fine within
my local community we all vote again I
I've suggested that there's a difference
between local community and federal I'm
fine with my local community voting for
school lunches or air conditioning or
whatever it is that we all agree to do
because the more local you get the more
homogeneity you get in terms of interest
and the more interest you have in your
neighbors all of that's fine I'm part of
a very very solid community in our
community we give to each other we have
minimum standards of helping one another
all that's wonderful when it comes to
the actual problem of Education what I
object to in the political sphere and
this happens all the time is everybody
is arguing on top of the iceberg about
how we can move the needle 05 percentage
points as opposed to the entire Iceberg
melting beneath them and we just ignore
that we pretend that that's just you
know sort of the natural consequence of
thing the AR of History suggests that
people are never going to get married
again well I mean actually what the Arc
of History suggests realistically
speaking is that the people who are not
getting married are not going to be
having kids and what it also suggests
the people who are married are going to
be having kids and so the demographic
profile actually over time is rather
going to shift toward people who are
having lots and lots of kids I'm married
I have four kids everyone in my
community is married that's like minimum
buying in my community is four kids okay
and so what's happening actually in
terms of demographics is that the people
who are more religious and getting
married are having more kids and so if
you're talking about the AR history
shifting toward I I would suggest that
actually demographically over time long
periods of time not over one generation
over long periods of time the only cure
for low birth rate is going to be the
people who get married and have lots of
kids yeah I don't necessarily disagree
with any of that but I'm just saying
that again on the I know you're upset
when I bring up the term marry ground um
I think that there are good
conversations to be had about people
getting married um because stable
families produce stable children that
are less likely to commit crime that
more likely to go to school they're more
likely to be productive memb of society
ET ET I'm not going to disagree with you
on any of that all of that is true um
it's just that sometimes when you bring
up any problem all of it will Circle
back to other things that makes it seem
like we can't make any progress in any
area without like fixing I mean I
literally just told you that on the
local level I'm fine for people voting
for so for instance on the local level
so for school funding school funding is
done I think generally per District so
what do you do when you have poor
districts that can't afford air
conditioner for their schools I mean the
idea there would be that presumably if
the society meaning the state and I
generally don't mean the federal state I
mean like the state of California for
example decides that everybody ought to
have air conditioning people will vote
for air conditioning and that's
perfectly legal and I don't think
there's anything morally objectionable
about that per se cool I also don't
think that that's going to heal anything
remotely like the central problem and I
think that what what what tends to
happen in terms of government is people
love arguing about the problems that can
be solved by opening a wallet and nobody
likes to solve a problem by you know
closing their sex life to one person for
example or having kids within a stable
religious community like the things
actually build
Society I'm fine with arguing about each
of these policies and and whether we
apply them or not is a matter generally
of pragmatism not morality it's a matter
of incentive structures not per se
morality because incentive structures do
have you know moral underpinings there
there's such a thing as you know for
example if you're going use a welfare
program you have to decide how effective
it is to what crowd it applies where the
cut offs are does it disincentivize work
does it not dis all of these are
pragmatic concerns but on a moral level
the generalized objection that I have to
people on the left side of the aisle is
that they like to FOC in these
conversations very often it feels as
though it's a conversation with with
people who are drunk searching under the
the lamp for their keys the problems
they want to look at are the problems
that are solvable by government and then
all the problems they don't want to look
at which are the actual giant monsters
luring in the dark and not particularly
solvable by government are the ones they
want to ignore and assume are just the
natural state of things and I don't
think that's correct at all and I one
billion per agree but then obviously my
criticism for the conservative side is
the exact opposite where where there are
Parts where government could remedy some
issues um for instance you know uh
children having sex with each other and
producing other children out of wedlock
like sometimes having after school
programs is nice to prevent that like I
didn't have time for these things when I
was in school I was doing football
practice I was doing Cross Country
Practice I went in early for a band you
know um I agree with you that sometimes
people only focus on one end of the
problem as a I hate to be that guy um
but as somebody that have you ever
watched The Wire sure I'm not going to
cite the wire as real life example but
like obviously there's only so much you
can do in a school When the Children
coming in are so beyond destroyed
because of the family life and
everything prior to them even getting to
school all that day so I agree
government is not like the solution to
Broken families that would never be the
case and it's actually not the solution
to education depending on the kind of
solutions that you're talking about some
solutions yes some solutions no yeah the
only thing I'm looking at is as I said
earlier just like these minimum
threshold things where it's like where
can government make because you
mentioned marginal which I think is a
really good way to look at things
there's marginal cost and marginal
utility to things where the first
thousand per student you spend might
give you a huge return but the extra
20,000 after I these are all pragmatic
discussions actually this is what we
used to cash out in legislatures before
they turned into platforms for people
Grand standing but yes sure okay
yeah